we slapped an experimental head rig on
his head and said now be the star of
this movie the actors behind the navi
and avatars dealt with long days limited
vision and heavily wired motion capture
suits there's a lot of work a lot of
body work and a lot of behavioral
work that i had to do long before
filming started the cast were brought
into the studio for a long and tiresome
full-body casting experience in order to
make these life-sized models the actors
had to sit with restrictive plastic wrap
all over their face while layers of
plaster cast were applied all while
unable to see smell or breathe very well
and this was just the beginning of the
process
while the cast had to suffer through the
arduous ordeal it was a major help to
the creative team who needed the molds
to create highly detailed scans to send
along to the designers that were then
able to create the incredible
transformation from human to navi or
avatar
all while keeping each character
visually comparable to the actor playing
them the idea that i had clung to for a
long time was this idea of mounting a
camera directly to the actor's head
those full body casts came in handy when
it came time to make specially fitted
head rigs that the actors had to wear
throughout their entire performance so
we wound up with a tight-fitting carbon
fiber
helmet this headgear was heavy duty a
kind of cross between a skull cap and a
helmet that were made to fit like skin
on the actors heads so they could keep
all the mocap markers steady these caps
weren't easy to wear since they had all
sorts of gear attached like wires
cat-like ears and even motion capture
ready hair not to mention the carbon
fiber arm with a tiny but powerful
camera on the end of it that reached
around to the front of the actor's face
while the addition of the camera was
necessary to capture the nuances of the
performer's facial movements and
expressions it could make actually
performing challenging as a camera in
front of the face could obstruct views
and get in the performer's way
fortunately the actors managed to break
through and performed with no bounds the
result is pretty incredible 100
committed performances
the mocap suits used in avatar truly
became like second skins for the actor
though they weren't always the most
comfortable skins
there is nothing natural feeling about a
full-body form-fitting suit kitted up
with wires and heavy battery packs
you've got a bunch of markers on the
actor's body that are being picked up by
hundreds of cameras very little time was
spent in the makeup chair as all that
had to be applied to the face were dots
for the motion capture and the wardrobe
department was really just the motion
capture suit department with the
distraction of all these technical
looking suits cameras and wires
everywhere an actor turned the one thing
they could keep a clear focus on was
each other's eyes since those were never
covered having that connection amidst
all the technology was key and a
definite motivator to help the actors
through when filming felt tough on top
of the actress's photograph then we
would turn her into a navi on top of the
body casts the team decided to obtain as
much visual reference as they could of
each cast member in the development
process each of the actors were brought
in for a special photo shoot one that
involved a giant sphere filled with
large bright lights and multiple cameras
surrounding inside the sphere the actors
were troopers through the process to
help the designers gather as much detail
about their physicality and facial
details the photo shoots didn't end in
the sphere though an incredible amount
of photos were taken while the actors
performed various activities including
archery and wacky facial expressions as
zoe saldana and sam worthington found
themselves running through the jungles
of hawaii they definitely experienced
the elements maybe a bit too intensely
for their liking i was i was naked
[Laughter]
for three days in hawaii since james
cameron wanted the actors to experience
these filming experiments as their
characters he had them in the actual
clothing their characters would wear and
that didn't consist of much we did a
couple of scenes and we ran around in
loincloth the fact caught the actors by
surprise as it never really occurred to
them just how minimal their actual
costumes were not an easy experience but
we have a feeling saldana and
worthington were very close after
enjoying that together if you haven't
gathered by now the preparation to bring
avatar to the screen was long and
intense but it did include a trip to
hawaii to explore and film in kauai
amongst the mountains and through the
jungles an incredible experience but
this wasn't a vacation this was work
which meant everyone had to deal with
the very real rainforest elements just
as their characters would have had to
the performers were even set up with
costume details like their tails and
their characters accessories while
saldana got to ditch the motion capture
suit for this she did need to wear what
her character would have and if you've
seen avatar you know it's not very much
this became especially tough on the days
when the weather wasn't so great and the
performers were facing all the elements
keep going let's go
every actor had to go through a very
intense training regimen before they
could even begin filming sam worthington
went through extensive boxing and
military training even getting the
chance to work with a former marine who
just happened to be james cameron's
brother john david cameron
worthington had to be confident enough
in his training to be able to give a
full performance while restricted by the
motion capture suit and helmet and he
definitely delivered
zoe saldana pretty much became an expert
at performing highly demanding physical
activities while wearing her full body
performance suit long hair on the cap
included the actress had to learn how to
shoot a bow and arrow both the human way
and the navi way left-handed and with
their hands reversed
while this was supernatural for the navi
it was far from simple for the
performers and the fact that they were
wearing their full motion capture suits
and headgear only added a layer of
difficulty and discomfort the training
was rigorous
two olympic team trainers were there to
whip the cast into shape and from what
we see in the movie they didn't
disappoint i had to take everything i
learned in training and applied to my
first day las alonso aka soote trained
so much that he was able to ride a horse
with speed and jump off all while
looking graceful this was vital since he
really was riding a horse when filming
and while in his wire and battery pack
covered suit these feats weren't just
difficult but dangerous as well wearing
the headgear meant the performer's view
could be obstructed by the camera in
front which is the last thing a person
would want riding a horse
the high-tech suits also spent some time
climbing up a model built in the studio
to represent the beanstalk the
performers were attached to wires with
heavy sandbags at the ends enabling the
actors to speedily scale their way up
translating to the animalistic
otherworldly movement we see on screen
as for the scenes when the characters
are soaring through the air when you see
them flying these things they are
working hard are we surprised the day
after filming these rigorous scenes was
always a tough one and left the actors
physically exhausted not to mention
overwhelmed by their second skin suits
as for the large group scenes terry
notary was brought in to lead the actors
through movement workshops and training
a rigorous process that was key for the
success of the film
hours were spent becoming fluent in the
navi physicality so they could all suit
up and perform massive dances like this
just seeing all the tech the performers
had to wear is overwhelming avatar is a
feast for the eyes and truly a triumph
for filmmaking these actors were nothing
short of brilliant to endure all they
did bringing their characters to the
screen while it wasn't under ideal
circumstances it seems like the hawaii
research trip was pretty incredible